this video is brought to you by
Skillshare
a wisecrack Jared in the pale flesh
again today we've got an episode for you
about Pokemon go urban exploration and
some dead French guy the usual
Pokemon go temporarily gripped the world
like an epidemic the augmented reality
mobile game just days after its release
was installed in 5% of all Android
devices and even surpassed tinder in
downloads to say that we were gripped by
polka mania all over again is an
understatement the media and now
wisecrack just wouldn't shut up about it
Pokemon goers have discovered dead
bodies been lured into being robbed
crashed their cars and even trolled the
Westboro Baptist Church at the same time
plenty of people were less than a namer
buy Pokemon go filmmaker Oliver Stone
decried the game's rampant data
collection as a new form of surveillance
capitalism he also warned that the idea
of people running around to catch
imaginary monsters as dictated by a
giant corporation can go by another name
totalitarianism
so is Pokemon go a nightmare confluence
of phone addiction and corporate
surveillance maybe let's find out
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of Pokemon go and for once
no spoilers ahead and it's hard Pokemon
go is a game about walking you saunter
over to a poky stop dash towards raid
stampede towards the Dragonite trespass
into a neighbor's yard stumble into a
crime scene and so on and while walking
may seem as philosophically unimportant
as an Adam Sandler movie you'd be
surprised but before we can understand
how Pokemon go radically changes how we
interact with physical spaces we need a
little history of walking unsurprisingly
walking played a prominent role in
society and tailed the rise of the
automobile besides getting people from
point A to point B walking was a sort of
sport and aristocratic circles as
Frederick grosse writes in his book a
philosophy of walking well-to-do men and
women would stroll around in fancy
clothes occasionally striking opposed to
whoo potential suitors it was kind of
like the physical manifestation of rich
people selfies on Instagram for others
walking was a wholly matter
every year scores of people would
undergo a pilgrimage to various
sanctified sites meanwhile philosophers
like Friedrich Nietzsche saw walking as
an invaluable part of the philosophical
process today our walking and movement
in general still serves a social
function though it's a little more
pragmatic now our morning commute
running to the grocery store picking up
sonny jim from soccer practice most of
these comings and goings are programmed
into our daily lives we move from place
to place generally unaware of our
surroundings and never venture far from
our planned route all to fulfill our
societal obligations as grosse writes
this kind of rushing around is always in
the service of doing something and never
to just be walking according to gross is
in its purest form about doing nothing
which allows us to rediscover the simple
joy of existing a kind of childlike
wonderment with the world surrounding us
some might argue that Pokemon go
according to this logic follows the
always doing something logic of our time
frantically running from polka stopped
to pokey stop chasing down legendary
raids and battling gyms isn't exactly
the kind of exploration Gross's riding
around will tackle that in just a second
but first let's talk about space every
street building and open space carries
with it an assumed social code we
wouldn't behave in an office building
the same way you would at a concert you
don't play football freeway and many
would say it's important to wear your
Black Sabbath t-shirt to church but
those social codes change with time and
culture public bathing used to be a
thing bars used to be a place to find a
date and rivers used to be a fine place
for you to drop trou and do your
business Pokemon go and the technology
it uses might change everything by
radically recoding the space that we
live in the game has literally mapped on
to reality an entirely new set of social
codes parks for hiking now more like a
sweet place to battle mu-2 churches for
worship now pokeballs for days
panicked crowd all running in the same
direct
could be a zombie apocalypse but it
could also be an unknown museums to
memorialize the millions of people
slaughtered more like okay seriously
don't play Pokemon go in Holocaust
Museum in short Pokemon go disrupts how
we perceive space there's a common fear
where Pokemon go should we really trust
a massive corporation with such intimate
knowledge of where we're going and how
we're getting there is it a little scary
that a company can so artfully tell us
where to go
Niantic has integrated sponsored poki
stops and Starbucks for instance was
more than happy to oblige the idea is
you get to buy a pumpkin spice latte
once you've decided to take a break from
catching mythical monsters so far aside
from some sponsored pokey stops Natick
has taken the high road organizing
things like beach cleanups for Earth Day
but that doesn't mean it can't go
downhill fairly quickly what if you
could pay Niantic a couple million
dollars to have a rare Pokemon spawn at
your political rally or worse your
friends improv show for French
philosopher Guy Debord modern capitalism
has neatly organized time and physical
space where we are where we're going and
when we're getting there is a function
of the total izing control the economy
plays in our lives we travel through
life mesmerized by our commodity filled
environment we go to work to make money
to a leisure activity to spend money go
home
go to sleep and repeat with a sort of
systemic pressure to do this in a more
and more productive way work harder
enjoy more sleepless you get the idea
for some Pokemon go easily fits this
dystopic narrative yesterday we were
mesmerized by billboards and where they
told us to go probably to some TGI
Fridays today we're mesmerized by our
phone screens and where they tell us to
go what's missing from all this is
chance randomness and discovery but
before you think we're being overly
paranoid edge lures those who decry
Pokemon go as the harbinger of some
dystopic augmented reality are only half
right
Pokemon go as Edwin Montoya Azaria
writes in the Hong Kong Review of Books
resembles a de rêve a rev
lucien arey strategy proposed by Debord
to combat the injured wrenched and
alienated ways in which we move through
cities de rêve which is French for
drifting means abandoning the
pre-programmed way in which we interact
with cities by performing a sort of
experiment in space wandering around
aimlessly de board encourages people to
walk around to be drawn in by their
surroundings interrogate them and to
give themselves up to randomness and
that's kind of what Pokemon go does
players venture to locations they never
would have dreamed of going to namely
outside but if you're anything like me
you've discovered new neighborhoods new
landmarks and even this one's a shocker
made friends in the meet space Pokemon
Co is combating the kind of social
alienation that our culture actively
promotes while most games have you glued
to a screen with headphones on Pokemon
go encourages you to explore and make
new friends after the raid system was
introduced you could battle boss level
Pokemon for a limited time with friends
or strangers they also recently rolled
out trading adding new ways to meet new
people it psychologists have even
noticed that the game was helping their
patients with anxiety and depression
by getting them to get out of the house
and socialize in this way Pokemon go
actively recode the space around us in a
positive way it might not be exactly the
kind of revolutionary walking that
Debord envisioned or the useless kind of
walking grosse writes about but it's
also better than the alternative that
our tech obsessed society offers us who
knows maybe Pokemon go is a gateway drug
for hiking and social interaction what
do you think wisecrack is Pokemon goes
Society Savior or a harbinger of dismal
times to come or is it just a game about
animals and balls let us know what you
think in the comments and as always
thanks for watching
hey wisecrack it's Alec polka master
extraordinaire writing this episode was
a ton of fun but we came across one big
problem Jared went on a much-deserved
vacation so in service of Jared's mental
health a bunch of us in the office have
to do his job for the next few weeks and
for those unaware he does everything he
headed scripts he directs he reviews
cuts
luckily Skillshare has us covered they
have classes on video editing with the
doh
from year 2018 for beginners and they
have DIY cinematography so he can keep
up that jared level quality but even if
you're not trying to run wisecrack or
build your own YouTube channel they have
a ton of classes maybe you want to make
the next Pokemon go Skillshare has crash
course in 3d game design join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare with a special offer just for
wisecrack fans get two months of
Skillshare for free to sign up visit the
link in the description or head to sk l
sh slash wisecrack 13 and get unlimited
access to over 20,000 classes today and
as always thanks for watching